mouth-watering smoky pulled pork with a
spicy chipotle mayonnaise that is the
most amazing port but that's the way
butts okay now this is incredible
there's the Charlotte yeah and look
there's the shoulder blade if you go
through here there's a knuckle there
that's connecting the top and that's why
it's called a but the slow you cook it
the more deuce here is and it's great
for big parties because you just come
along and get you fork and shred it a
delicious smoky mayonnaise and your way
onions into half and half again again
they leave the roots on I care because I
want this to sit underneath the poor
it gives it a chance to cook evenly and
doesn't get dry in the bottom really
important okay no I'll peel the garlic
okay I'd like you to crush the garlic
we're gonna make a really nice little
paste okay
so I make it nice good girl crush
Tommy cut there now
this is a beauty smoke so three nice
tablespoons in okay
two large tablespoons of brown sugar
salt please pepper
okay so gonna form a nice paste now
olive oil in mixed that some thyme in
there so we got a sort of fragrant rough
time stalks underneath so that's the
more flavor going on the bottom pour
that all over now this is very gonna be
really quick okay rub that nice argit
enormous it's exactly that smells
amazing awesome
just drizzle a little touch of olive on
top of that for me I keep the pork nice
and moist
lovely
like some of the best party dishes the
marinating the pork shoulder can be done
days in advance so if I wasn't doing
this for Sunday and start marinating
Thursday Friday so it gets even tastier
it's very easy five and a half to six
hours in the oven at 140 while I put but
slowly roasted meg and I are gonna pimp
some shop-bought mayonnaise I don't like
just plain mayonnaise there's so many
things twist yeah there's so many things
somebody excitedly didn't do with it
right salt pepper and a touch of honey
sweetness sweetness but there's some
heat coming okay
and I've got a little bit of you know
this Holy Smoke
- holy ice once you've made this
dressing you can sit in the fridge great
ropa sandwiches yeah any senators but
goes brilliantly well with pork now just
have a little taste I've never had this
before it's so good and I spoon of
mustard so that's a nice spicy
mayonnaise after five and a half hours
in the oven a pork is nearly ready but
just time to knock up a couple of
tried-and-tested party favors first
deliciously simple cheesy crushed
potatoes cut potatoes into even chunks
and submerge in salted boiling water
skins and all
meanwhile finally thy sweet pickled
gherkins or cornichons trim and finely
chopped spring onions and great some
nutty Greer cheese
when the potatoes are cooked through
drain roughly crush and add your spring
onions and gherkins
season to taste and gently combine
before a final sprinkling of grated
Greer these simple cheesy crush potatoes
are equally delicious served hot or cold
now I want something sort of raw like a
slaw something quite refreshing so I'm
gonna make a really nice fresh broccoli
salad now these are called florets
that's the best part of the broccoli ok
the bit that everybody wants once
they're off I'm gonna slice the broccoli
okay never had real broccoli before
always been kept worried when you dress
this with the dressing it's incredible
now little seasons early on yeah
now for the dressing fresh yogurt in
teaspoon of sugar please that it's not
cider vinegar yeah then you go finely
chop it up in with a broccoli
so delicious roasted always into the
pocket that gives that nice sort of
chewy texture right lift up your bowl
please nice and gently half of that
thank you and stop and then mix that
with me
kick you a real taste
so good and is it kind of salad that
doesn't wilt couple of hours later it's
still crunchy cuz the Rafi's raw raw
broccoli salad Chipotle and then let me
the pork out of this look at this Megan
honestly that amazing is beautiful
that's improve
[Music]
now that goes the table like that you
have a tiny bit before we go to the
table mega a little bit honestly don't
tell mom thank you
good idea oh my dear
that is incredible sorry
he promised me you don't do the rest me
to your boyfriend
[Music]
this is my ultimate easy party dinner
melt-in-your-mouth slow-cooked smoky
pulled pork with a spicy - poly
mayonnaise and quick simple sides of
crushed cheesy potatoes and a light and
healthy broccoli slaw deliciously yummy
dishes that will have your family
friends and work buddies coming back for
more
[Music]